plenty of actors have starred in movies
or TV shows that most people don't know
about but whoever knew that Cameron
Boyce did this the late Cameron Boyce
once starred in a movie back in 2008
that his fans have likely forgotten
about especially those who know him for
his family friendly work Boyce who died
in 2019 is most well known for his
performances and a handful of Disney
Channel shows and movies that were
released throughout the 2010s Boyce
began to earn some early attention in
2011 when he landed the recurring role
of Luke Ross on the Debbie Ryan LED
series Jesse Boyce's Fame continued to
grow in 2015 when he appeared as Carlos
the son of Cruella Deville in the Disney
Channel original movie descendants he
went on to reprise his role as Carlos in
three more descendants movies outside of
his work for the Disney Channel Boyce
also had notable recurring roles in the
HBO original series Mrs Fletcher and the
Amazon Prime Musical TV show Paradise
City long before he appeared in those TV
shows however voice made his big big
screen debut in a now forgotten horror
movie in 2008 Cameron Boyce starred as a
young boy named Michael in Alexander
aja's supernatural horror film mirrors
the film follows a former cop as he and
his family are targeted by a malevolent
force that is attempting to use mirrors
to make its way into the physical world
you gotta keep going all right okay
a remake of a 2003 South Korean horror
movie titled into the mirror this movie
wasn't particularly well received by
critics or casual viewers when it was
initially released in 2008 while the
movie managed to more than double its 35
million dollar production budget at the
box office it currently boasts a low 15
Tomato Meter score on Rotten Tomatoes
The film's Audience score sits slightly
higher at 44 percent but that isn't high
enough to earn mirrors a fresh rating in
his review of the film for Entertainment
Weekly Owen gleiberman wrote the
director Alexander Aja knows how to
reflect the fear in people's heads but
he gets too ensnared in a backstory
that's just Gothic business as usual
however in his write-up of the movie for
real film reviews David nusair actually
praised mirrors observing that it is
quote often far more entertaining than
it has any right to be notably mirrors
marked voices first and only horror
movie fortunately it's quite clear that
the film's port reception hasn't tainted
Voice's Legacy and any tangible way at
just 20 years old Boyce died from
epilepsy in 2019 cutting short his
burgeoning screen career voice turned in
his final screen performance as Simon in
the first season of paradise city which
premiered on Amazon nearly two full
years after his death but despite the
fact that Boyce's career ended in 2019
his legacy continues to live on in fact
many of the actors and collaborators
with whom he worked over the years have
been consistently willing to sink his
phrases many have spoken openly about
the positive experiences that they
shared with him following Boyce's tragic
death several of his most notable
co-stars took to social media to pay
tribute to him Adam Sandler for instance
tweeted Too Young Too Sweet too funny
just the nicest most talented and most
decent kid around thank you Cameron for
all you gave to us so much more was on
the way all our hearts are broken in
addition to Sandler several of voices
Disney Channel collaborators were also
quick to publicly pay their own tributes
three years after his death voices
descendants co-star Sophia Carson even
took a moment to remember him writing on
Instagram three years without you I love
you forever I miss you forever Carson's
post proves that among other things the
death of Boyce continues to be felt
deeply by both his fans and loved ones
and while boys will no doubt be missed
there's no denying that he left behind
an impressive assortment of movie and TV
performances that his fans could
continue to enjoy for many years to come
including his supporting turn as Michael
in mirrors
thank you